and I get the privilege of helping our
students achieve meaning and fulfillment
out of their college years it's also a
time for immense personal growth and
self-reflection and well-being as a
graduate student I feel that my
professors care about me and remember
that we are all together this is a
community we are not alone you are not
alone when I'm hoping that students see
CMU as a place of growth lean on each
other this is one of the most profound
ways in which we can act as a community
and thrive as individuals makes you in
your home for people from all over the
world and just you know feel a sense of
belonging you will succeed often and you
may fail sometimes but you will never be
a failure at Carnegie Mellon you'll be
you